welcome to the frontline of Britain's
homeless crisis every night you go at
the same time and same people waiting
Kelly's a volunteer delivering food to
the homeless and there's one person she
thinks about most on the street and
that's a young man called Tom every time
I see Tom I feel sorry for him because
he's just not getting any help from
anywhere with the poor getting poorer
and with cuts to mental health services
the number of people sleeping rough in
the streets has doubled in the past ten
years tom
the young man Kelly was talking about is
here and his story is a shocking one he
was born with a spine condition he's
incontinent jobless homeless he has no
family no health or care he's on his own
your medical condition makes it very
difficult at it especially in the
evenings when everything's closed where
I would need to use a loo normally that
does make it very very difficult for me
but I did with it as best as I can to
put it basically do you think cyanide he
should be looking at you and saying you
shouldn't be on the streets you need
proper care yeah in a way yes I do there
are a lot of times where I don't wanna
doesn't be blunt don't want to be here
but you just kind of forget all of it
just day by day is which is what I do I
try to take every day as it comes and
don't look too far into the future and
just do I can't keep myself going and
survive and eat and sleep and whatever
else because of his medical condition
the night shelter won't let Tom in to
stay all three parties are making big
promises about ending rough sleeping and
putting money into adult social care the
next day I arranged to meet back up with
Tom this time down at the beach you know
whoever becomes the next prime minister
and they look at your story disabled
young lad on the street needs care needs
a home needs a different decent safety
net what should they learn from your
story it's not the right thing to do
like I said just give people chances
who exactly cares for people like Tom
and who pays is a big issue in this
election how much longer can you do this
not much longer if I am honest I don't
want to do this for much longer
Tom's at the very heart of this crisis
living it stuck in a brutal routine
nowhere to turn and nowhere to go Nick
Martin Sky News weston-super-mare